[Music]
so far every person featuring our
Employee of the Month segment has been a
person but today we are thrilled to
honor a dog the dog is called bass bass
is a Belgian Shepherd served in the U.S
Marine Corps he's been on more than 350
explosive sweeps in Iraq Afghanistan and
Somalia he saved a lot of lives by
sniffing out at least five Taliban IEDs
during a raid and for that he's been
awarded the animal version of Victoria
Cross
multi-purpose canine bash joins us now
with his former Handler retired Marine
staff sergeant Alex Schnell Alex and
bass thank you so much for coming on
um tell us the basics if you would about
bass how old is he what did he do what's
he like
yeah absolutely Tucker thanks for having
us on of course bass and I served for
five years together in the Marine Corps
and then you mentioned that we did the
three overseas combat deployments
um bass's main job as a military working
dog he's kind of a specialized type it's
called a multi-purpose canine and his
three main capabilities were explosive
detection the apprehension or bike
capability and then being able to track
enemy combatants and over the last two
decades the greatest threat that
Coalition forces faced were those IEDs
to improvised explosive devices and
Military working dogs have by far been
the best asset to try and mitigate that
threat so that was primarily what we
relied on bass for
so his breed is reportedly the smartest
in the world the smartest dogs there are
that's what people say is that is that
your experience
with him
yeah I mean uh Belgian males are very
smart very intelligent by nature but
bass especially is one of the most if
not the most intelligent dogs that I've
had the pleasure of working with and I
think that's just due to his resiliency
and the ability for him to kind of read
the emotions in a certain situation
especially on the battlefield and be
able to perform when the stakes are that
high I mean it's a lot to ask an animal
to do that and the fact that he has done
that on so many occasions is just it's
pretty special
it's a lot to ask a person to do that
and it's amazing that dogs do that so I
think the question a lot of people have
is you work with this dog in in combat
Arenas and then both of you leave the
service do you stay with Bass
yeah uh
bass retired about two weeks before I
was honorably discharged actually so I
got to adopt him directly after I left
my time with active duty and it doesn't
always work out that way it has a lot to
do with the timing of the unit and the
specific dog in our situation we're
pretty fortunate to be able to do that
and one thing I wanted to highlight with
the retirement for these dogs is that
once they leave active duty they no
longer receive medical care or support
from the U.S government and that's one
thing we'd love to change but that's
kind of where some non-profits step in
and I'm involved with a group called the
United States war dogs Association
uswardogs.org and they help provide
medical care and financial support for
these retired military working dogs that
have given so much for us and bass has
really enjoyed his retirement but last
October was diagnosed with a pretty
aggressive form of blood cancer called
hemangiosarcoma and we had to have
emergency surgery he's done some
chemotherapy I'm happy to say that he's
going or he's in remission which is
fantastic but those medical bills are
expensive and U.S war dogs you know
footed the whole bill for his treatment
and provides medical care for over 1200
dogs every single month which gives them
you know the quality of life that these
guys deserve after doing so much for us
without even really having a say in it
you know
I love that and I love that there's a
group like that this really is
Underneath It All a really nice country
the nice the nicest Alex thank you for
coming on and it's great to meet you
Bass
absolutely thank you Tucker appreciate
it thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight